así que ahora tenemos nuestro cable
amarillo que está conectado a nuestro
interruptor aquí y lo que vamos a hacer
es vamos a pasar este cable a las
baterías aquí y la mejor manera que he
encontrado para hacer esto es quitar las
baterías
damos la vuelta al cable vamos a hacerlo
así
veamos qué tan largo debe ser pues
necesitamos que este cable se cruce con
el resorte de acá podemos recortar esta
parte así
y luego vamos a tener nuestros pelas
cables aquí
vamos a cortar esto
ahora tenemos el cable pelado
tomaremos el cable y lo pondremos justo
detrás de este resorte
es un buen momento de usar los alicates
de punta fina aquí
muy bien el resorte debe sujetar ese
cable contra el interior del soporte de
la batería
y podemos volver a poner nuestras
baterías
y allí va pueden escucharlo funcionar
entonces cuando cerramos este
interruptor podemos apagar la
alimentación todo bien
ahora hagamos el resto del bote todavía
nos queda mucho por armar
vamos a tomar otro interruptor y lo
usaremos para encender y apagar los
globos oculares led
así que lo armaremos
y aquí están los leds y vamos a
conectarlos
estos leds tienen una patita larga y una
patita corta
podemos verlo en ambos leds
ahora la patita larga es el positivo y
los leds están polarizados lo que
significa que el positivo es importante
tenemos que conectarlo al lado positivo
del circuito de lo contrario no
funcionará
la corriente solo puede fluir a través
del led en una dirección
así que lo que quiero hacer es doblar
las patitas un poco así y en realidad
pueden mirar dentro del led y ver que
hay una forma diferente y un tamaño
diferente para las diferentes patas
entonces las dos piezas más pequeñas
están conectadas a las patitas más
largas ese es el lado positivo
y estos son los lados negativos aquí y
siempre podemos volver a verificarlo
estirando las patitas nuevamente si
queremos tener una idea de cuál es más
larga
y la patita más larga está nuevamente
conectada a esa pequeña pieza del
material en el interior
muy bien
hagamos que este centro sea positivo y
podemos hacerlo simplemente retorciendo
estos cables o estas patitas juntas de
esta manera
ahora para que los leds funcionen
correctamente
deben tener resistencias necesitamos
resistor es porque de lo contrario los
leds extra eran demasiada corriente de
las baterías y se quemarán entonces
vamos a tomar un resistor y enrollarlo
alrededor de la patita negativa los
resistor es pueden ir técnicamente en
positivo o negativo
aquí vamos
y haremos lo mismo de este lado aquí
todo bien así que tenemos muchas piezas
que están conectadas allí y ahora
recuerden
tenemos
parece que tenemos nuestro negativo de
nuestra batería aquí
y parece que lo positivo puede haberse
salido
podemos agregar eso de nuevo
sigamos adelante y pongamos nuestras
antenas vamos a doblar nuestros clips
pensándolo bien haremos las antenas en
un momento terminemos primero los ojos
let
entonces vamos a tomar el cable rojo y
ese será el positivo o cable central y
sólo necesitamos recortarlo un poco
así
estamos retorciendo este cable alrededor
del centro porque esto será el positivo
y así los cables negativos se conectarán
a los negativos
entonces este interruptor nos permitirá
encender y apagar a nuestros ojos leds
pero tenemos un cable desconectado aquí
por lo que necesitamos volver a conectar
lo positivo a eso allí y realmente no
necesitamos que sea tan largo así que
vamos a recortarlo
necesitamos un cable rojo allí y no lo
tenemos ahora así que vamos a volver a
conectarlo
y tenemos un pequeño trozo que sobresale
así que solo podemos
pueden escuchar que golpea los
interruptores y se enciende y apaga
entonces una vez que tenemos el cable
rojo allí podemos seguir adelante y
soltarlo en su lugar
y podemos ver que parece que tenemos una
conexión bastante buena con el positivo
para que este interruptor encienda y
apague nuestros ojos leds
voy a alejar la toma un poco aquí
así para que este interruptor encienda y
apague nuestros ojos leds necesitamos
conectarlo desde negativo a través de
esto al positivo
pero antes de hacer eso sigamos adelante
y coloquemos un poco de soldadura en las
conexiones aquí para asegurarnos de que
no se separen de nuestros leds
y en realidad se puede ver la soldadura
arriba y abajo de los cables
ahora necesitamos conectar otro cable
aquí
a estos veamos tomemos un cable blanco
y lo pelamos un poco
así
vamos a torcer las dos patitas de los
registres juntas
así
y es importante que los cables
permanezcan separados
por lo que podemos poner algo de cinta
sobre eso algo de cinta aislante aquí
para mantener todo separado porque
obviamente si el cable positivo y el
negativo se tocan van a hacer
cortocircuito
así que sigamos adelante y veamos dónde
podemos conectar esto muy bien
queremos asegurarnos de tener esta
conexión física sólida antes de poner la
soldadura
aquí vamos
muy bien